[Musique]
on n'a pas tiré les leçons du passé à
chaque coup d'état
on ne lit pas comme on dit le plus haut
grade leulier de l'histoire de la guinée
si vous souvenez par exemple rapidement
comme monsieur sékou touré mois 4,4 les
militaires ont pris le pouvoir ils ont
perpétué le système sans faire aucune
analyse pour essayer de faire un
diagnostic afin d'éviter que l'on mette
en commettre les mêmes erreurs du passé
je dirais pour vous répondre aujourd'hui
on a l'impression que c'est un éternel
recommencement
[Musique]
vous êtes si décision cette clique de
façon très simple c'est que monsieur
alpha condé a été votre rue même d'un
coup d'état constitutionnel parce qu'il
a tripatouillé la constitution pour sur
toi y ait un troisième mandat et
aujourd'hui le débat se pose au niveau
même de la communauté
est ce qu'il ne faut pas aujourd'hui
mettre sur le même sur la même base les
coups d'état conscient et les coups
d'état et la liesse populaire s'explique
pour une rentrée sans
lunettes est dans une crise politique
sous laquelle est venue s'ajouter une
délicate crise économique c'est une
charge de plans qui était sur la terre
du peuple de guinée et cinq certains a
été pour le peuple guinéen une vraie
délivrance
pendant dix ans la guinée avec un régime
autoritaire c'est le paradoxe à la tête
de l'état guinéen à l'émission a connu
qui a été présenté comme un opposant
défenseurs de la démocratie
malheureusement il est nul très vite à
notre classe et il a instauré dans le
pays pendant dix ans mais un régime
autoritaire la population et vilaine a
vu un certain la fin d'un calvaire c'est
pourquoi il ya eu cette liesse populaire
mais je pense pas que cette liesse
populaire est un chèque en blanc le
donner aux nouvelles autorités
guinéennes
[Musique]
personnellement j'ai une véritable
inquiétude sur cette transition depuis
le 5 septembre on actuellement à l'étape
de commerce c'est vrai que les acteurs
peut-être qu'ils ont été posées ya eu
beaucoup de promesses je crains fort que
nestor encore sur un régime autoritaire
parce qu'on commence à voir à fleurir
dans tout le pays notamment à conakry
les portraits du nouveau président et on
est pressé personnellement je sais
pouvoir tout de suite les activant
exposé parce que cette transition il
devait se limiter à mon avis sur deux
actes principe pour deux axes principaux
c'est l'organisation a grimpé de
direction pour permettre le retour de
l'homme et surtout essayer de stabiliser
et de refonder de les lancer les parts
de nettoyage de l'annonciation parce que
le paiement de ces crises il n'y a pas
un problème ethnique a pas de division
ethniques en guinée il ya une
instrumentalisation ne sais quoi mais
surtout il ya une politisation à
outrance de la nation guinéenne et si
cette jeune fille solidité juste à
organiser des élections et à vendre
l'administration ne passions je pense
qu'avec un peu mais je crains fort que
on est que cette gen prend goût au
pouvoir et trouver des mécanismes pour
s'éterniser au pouvoir
[Musique]
le colonel mamadou
un parcours
celle de la légion étrangère en france
il est revenu dans les années 2004-2006
neuvilloise en guinée et en 2016 de chez
alpha condé lui a confié la direction
des forces spéciales donc c'est
quelqu'un qui a un parcours leur
religion et qui revenait à un gilet pour
diriger les forces spéciales il est
marié à une française et père de quatre
enfants c'est quelqu'un pour le mans -
j'ai
confiance dans ses déclarations mais
comme on lit ici les promesses
n'engagent que ceux qui les croient je
suis très réservé quant à la capacité de
ce comité national de défense de la
démocratie par le développement de
gérer cette transition sans anicroche
parce que
les premières décisions qui vont être
prises vont avoir une indication sur la
volonté de cette jeune d'enlèvement
processeur ou de s'éterniser au pouvoir
[Musique]